forty-three seconds of logos not enough
Galahad would be amazing at cinemasins
but hey we all know why you a
highly-trained secret service guy missed
it the plot if this movie has the balls
to go for the snow globe transition shop
are there seriously not any guards
outside this door right now
I have people inside doing absolutely
nothing furthermore any random asshole
can knock on the door in the middle of
nowhere and you just answer it with the
slightest amount of caution and then
Lancelot who was doing all this on his
own doesn't kill the obvious bad guy at
the door right away okay so how did
gazelle managed to walk across the floor
without anyone hearing her this floor
isn't carpeted so how did she run
without it sounding like Oscar Pistorius
running from a burglar when it comes
down to it the shot represents the love
and hate of the Star Wars saga this
hologram meeting intrigues me do all of
these agents bring their coasters and
drinking glasses with them into the
field just in case one of their brothers
dies and they need to toast him and why
does the hologram camera pick up the
glass and coaster but nothing else about
their surrounding and how did all these
busy agents schedules align perfectly to
have this meeting tried picking a more
suitable candidate this time you're
still holding a grudge about the last
guy this one recruited 17 years later
what's the statute of limitations on a
plum recommendation to the Kingsmen
forces these excessive liquor bottles
are an orgy of evidence that suggests
eggsy lives a less than Pleasant home
life eggsy
really I'm not British enough to know if
this kid's name is a flat-out joke or
just charming they show you mother F we
can be good company mom moves on from
her dead husband and starts picking
nothing but loser asshole boyfriends
cliche and while the baby really knew
when to start crying to put an
exclamation point on this horrible
situation are you mental cus you just
get that lot to do you I don't know
about you but if I go into a pub and see
a whole bunch of people I hate sitting
nearby I don't drink in that pup but hey
anyway we can introduce characters in a
really slips out manner is fine by me
eggsy breaks this necklace completely
instead of just taking three seconds to
unclasp at the normal way and preserve
the necklace for future use yeah these
guys have a synced up drinking schedule
or something this guy only sees the
tooth because he too is experiencing
slow-motion right now oh sure people
have fun ragging on the Bourne movies
for shaky-cam fight scenes but this
movie gets all the love for what amounts
to many missing frames jumpy can fight
scenes I am absolutely fine with
umbrella assisted brawling but I drawn a
line at amnesia darts goddamn it also
Harry will totally not amnesia dark
these guys because he needs them to tell
eggsy step-dad about the fight and
conduct an elaborate test to examine
eggsy's loyalty but they know all sorts
of stuff they shouldn't know and
good amnesia darted 20th Century Fox
logo overload story of the internet
billionaires rise to power is expected
to be this award seasons why also this
scroll says breaking news but all the
ones to report is a number to text and
an email address damn how many rolls of
paper towel does this damn kitchen eat
and this one on the dispenser has the
towels facing wall first and I can hate
that eggsy walks into his house like
deans buddies weren't going to report
the incident at the pub but besides that
damn those guys woke up from
unconsciousness and called Dean about it
really fast didn't they eggsy is
suddenly a parkour badass independent
international intelligence agency
operating at the highest level of
discretion that is unless you're beating
up a bunch of bullies in a pub and don't
shoot them without a measured art thing
and they call their boss so you can test
your recruits loyalty that's the
exception late late so wait a minute one
of your tasks after Lancelot died was to
find a recruit are you telling me that
you waited until eggsy got in trouble
and called you out of the blue to
finally decide on one they do not have a
plan B in this scenario amazing all the
with eggsy happened in the last 24 hours
widest recruitment ever those idiots who
call themselves politicians that bared
their heads in the sand and stood for
nothing but reelection
is this guy a bad guy or simply bright
discount back of Obama's head is
discount this asshole turned on his
bright ass light just to walk ten feet
to the toilet making him a bad roommate
and an enemy to darkness I know most of
these guys are basically geniuses from
renowned universities but where do you
learn this type of survival you mean
you've run across stories where people
were drowning and they you showerheads
and toilets as a breathing apparatus how
often does that come up I think I'll
believe the toilet scuba tank before I
believe someone can punch a two-way
mirror to death underwater I mean Jesus
let's talk about how men in black this
movie is secret spy fighting force
multiple new recruits competing for one
spot one oddball candidate comes up with
a unique solution to the test scenario
while everyone else succeeds the
traditional way I mean this movie is fun
and I have no problem with it but can we
all just admit the screenwriters started
with a literal copy of the Men in Black
screenplay and then just tweaked all the
specifics smacking mark hamill for any
reason you know what if not for Fifty
Shades of Grey
I would not be noticing overly large
panda art but here I am noticing overly
large panda art and yet another movie
and I'm sick of it this is the Ender's
Game divergent portion of the movie
meanwhile at Tony Stark's European home
all it takes is a couple of head fakes
and you can totally dodge every single
bullet two guards at close range shoot
at easily identifiable scarf or villains
evil plan is easily identifiable
eggsy somehow knows to operate this
clipboard and call up YouTube or
whatever it is that gives you instant
news stories although let's be honest
this clipboard
doesn't do absolutely no one is
suspicious of free phones post Edward
Snowden don't you think several hackers
would figure this is on the up and up
within hours of its availability and do
you really think big cellular isn't
gonna hire henchmen to kill Valentine
for theirs before non main characters
jump out of the plane and it takes her
30 seconds to finally jump unless the
plane is simply hovering which we know
it ain't
this chick somehow finds her teammates
and is able to catch up to them in no
time even though the plane was probably
several miles ahead of the original drop
point but hey man we all know times like
this wait for a movie drama so it turns
out everyone shoots work but this
deception could easily have killed more
than one person more excessive panda art
convinces me samuel l.jackson 'he's
character has a Red Room of sex pain
somewhere in this dojo I guess all the
product placement in this movie is a
joke which I'm totally fine with but I'm
not fine with as the rick asshole
serving mcdonald's to his rich clients i
mean even as a joke how does he expect
to woo the right people with this also
humic movie you like spy movies mr.
Devere nowadays through little serious
for my taste
Matthew Vaughn commentary accidentally
makes it into the actual script and
therefore the movie now of the kid that
was my dream job gentleman spy I think I
know why you never became one
considering the Kingsmen recruiting
standards did I just read racial subtext
and a not so serious spy flick well I
guess that's a sin on me oh and the
movie South Glade Mission Church is a
hate group based in Kentucky oh no not
another spy movie going to Kentucky the
British people think of Kentucky is the
supervillain playground in the United
States so he's got a bunch of
celebrities and dignitaries held
prisoner and not one of them decides to
promote his product in exchange for
freedom which is okay fine but he's just
casually running a prison now for 300
famous people hey everyone you know how
I hate to be annoying but that picture
they're holding in their hand is
impossible no matter how awesome the
transition is you know I think if I woke
up tied to some train tracks and I knew
I was in an organization that liked to
fuck with people I might take this
almost too calmly in other words the
fact that you've been tricked so many
times eventually lead you to the
conclusion that you're not in a
situation you think you are and
therefore the results of such a test are
skewed I mean this guy is a total
dumbass
I used biometrics for clocking in at
work and I didn't hurt what the hell
kind of biometrics is this this fitting
room leads to a weapons and gadgets aim
burr that you can access simply by
pulling a hook something that could
easily be done on accident now maybe the
tailor outside doesn't let you go in
this room if you're a normal person but
why is it all lift a chance Galahad
needed to use a biometric system to make
the floor descend earlier so why not
here - do you know since the door is
closed I might suggest Lock & Co
participant changes lock there's an
smoked-fish how did he make that leap in
logic I have trouble understanding you
people sometimes y'all funny that's
racist
shoot the dog and he doesn't which is
fairly ridiculous at this stage when
every test has been a bit of a practical
joke and how has he not heard of this
classic spy school or they ask you to
shoot one of your loved ones and the gun
is filled with blanks at least two girls
go bulls yeah but what happened if both
of them pass this test is there
something even more double you have in
store they somehow don't know they're
being messed with would they have both
passed you'd have to have a girl in your
knights of the round table motif I guess
she'd be Quinn of ear but then that
opens up a whole bunch of other
questions namely if two dudes passed the
test eggsy stole this car but how did
you get off the Kingsmen estate with it
just in case you confused it with
Kentucky Care's extent movie saves a lot
of money by simply recording a Westboro
Baptist Church meeting okay I'm just
gonna remove five sins for this scene
right here anybody mind that I mean free
bird and everything but God Matthew
Vaughn
I've been peeking into my fantasy action
scene database how was it after that
melee there are about a hundred people
still in their pews like they never once
got up now I'm gonna tell you my whole
plan and then I'm gonna come up with
from a third and convoluted way to kill
you and you'll find an equally
convoluted way to escape well this ain't
that kind of movie
haha wink at the audience enough and
they will forgive anything right No
eggsy drives to the Kingsmen shop which
means he has to go through all the
biometrics to make the floor descend so
he can take the shuttle to go to the
mansion so why is he able to do that
when he failed the test and is no longer
part of the program
somehow Arthur has this ridiculous scar
on his neck and nobody who knows what
that means ever saw it until eggsy that
is in surgery wow isn't that lucky
exit killed Arthur just before he got a
text telling him exactly where he needs
to go and the remaining Kingsman can
stop Valentine's plan it's almost like
Matthew Vaughn recycled some of his
x-men first class ideas into this movie
I'm supposed to be
offer these invitations in his room give
him this
yeah but didn't Valentine monitor all of
his people so that if they were about to
blab he'd kill him doesn't he know
Arthur is dead
and even if he didn't doesn't he know
what Arthur looks like wouldn't there be
other giveaways like the fact that eggsy
doesn't have a scar on his neck let's
turn those frowns upside down Chester
King mr. King welcome I mean seriously
absolutely no photo ID required firing
and trained well I know you want to
create obstacles for your heroes to
overcome during the big climax but does
it have to be so suspiciously timed to
the exact moment of success you know
this movie isn't the type of movie where
the villain tells the hero is evil plan
and puts him in an easily escapable
situation but it is the type of movie
where the hero gets a last-second break
to help foil an evil plan I realize
maybe he changed clips off screen but it
sure looks like this movie thinks
eggsy's gun can hold all the bullets all
these guys miss eggsy who isn't dodging
or anything that missile took forever to
hit its target with no time to spare
this is right
I'll show you yours well it's urgent
climax seems like the perfect time for a
weird men in black dramatic weapon
earning bulk when you're on a secret
plane that you can only access by being
a Kingsman in the first place why do you
need a secret compartment for weapons
vollendroff razor for a present could
mean anything
a bomb why not just say 35 soldiers just
ran down the tunnel after you yo none of
these guys thinks to shoot the legs and
feet where were these assholes when the
other dudes were trying to kill eggsy
earlier also seeing all these soldiers
makes me realize after Valentine execute
this plan who's going to do all the
dirty work so that these rich people can
continue living their lives in a rich
Manor maybe there's some subtext there
but no one calls him out on it I mean
it's not like all the people who do jobs
of the world are gonna be around well I
guess it's a good thing that each of
these prison cells has a fortified milk
egg seeking shelter in these implants
blow up Domino style instead of all at
once
also why are all the head implant
explosions so colourful why did someone
take the time to make sure there were
four distinct color possibilities yeah
what do you want me to do now random
girl I've never met or talked to before
and I'm completely trusting because you
mentioned eggsy's name no god save the
world if you save the world we can do it
in the asshole power of boners was
already strong enough to save the world
but Swedish anal sex boners that's a
whole different ball of wax and
unexpected Lube purchases okay but when
they save the day later how are there
not still hundreds of thousands possibly
millions of dead people from this global
rampage
with a great many of these fight scenes
is stuff like this that looks vacant
Michelle is now in the bathroom but
despite the fact that she's in a frenzy
this scene will end a lot less
tragically than it should have
I'm glad Eddie's mom didn't kill his
baby sister but almost everyone else's
baby sister got killed during this so an
anal sex could be said that the end of
this movie got downright cheeky am i
right I'm all for Dean getting his ass
kicked and beat his ass in the credits
your verbal I am mr. kobayashi Kobayashi
kobayashi tell me every last detail I
work for Kaiser solenoid you know what
they call a quarter pounder with cheese
in France ROI allergy Royale with cheese
you know why they call it that because
of the metric system check out the big
brain on a brad a pen this is like class
four grenade
three clicks arms the 4 second fuse
another three disarms it get out I knew
you couldn't make it to Galahad I
switched glasses when your back was
turned
are you full global warming is the fever
mankind if the virus human beings are
disease a cancer of this planet you're a
plague
back out back out bugging me bugging me
baby
Oh spose Willie and